driver hands
[Music]
up window I I got window I got commands
driver with your left hand open your
driver
door I got
hands okay I'm going get give me one
second somebody tell me yeah give me one
second I'll step out for me I can't my
seat Bel
still I'm on the
phone I got this one if you want to it
all
right somebody please like explain
everything to you bro step out for
okay car step out I the car is still in
Drive okay step out from my
brother you got any knives or guns or
anything like that on you I do have my
my gun on me where's it at here in the
all right put your hands on the leave
them right
there somebody tell me what's going on
yeah give me one second my man I'm going
to tell you
okay do you have an ID on you by any
chance yeah it's right here in my pocket
right here uhuh in my
what's your name brother my name is
Ricardo okay here's deal Ricardo you
have a warrant out of Atlanta for
homicide so keep your hands on this car
don't do anything dumb we're going to
put these handcuffs behind you okay
that's
yeah yeah could you call her
404 do you have a bluetoo yeah I'm
talking to you take that Bluetooth out
real Quick's about to call my
mom you got this hand right
[Music]
here than for being calm and not getting
too excited
appreciate
huh you got anything else on you need to
know
about you did tell them go ahead and
start
confirmation
thank you
SARS you ain't got nothing else on you
no no
sir is this in our
phone all we'll put we're going to put
this in there with your phone
Russ if y'all want to y'all can put him
either in my car and one of Y cars and
we'll get him from
there I'm just cruising up and down
fucking 29 I just ran this tag and it
was he went by me just to singing I run
the tag and I'm like 83 shit I was like
aggravate the so I look
said
well one of you guys have to do it but
I'll do the report I'm trying to see if
they'll meet with us if not up somebody
have to end up taking the F for
me
you see that front end
how yeah so this is he passed me and I
noticed all this
yeah and so I just kind of whipped
around I was just cruising up behind him
and ran the
tag nice start
today some old m anything in here no
it's
marijuana just as uh scales
[Music]
WS the one time Union is actually close
by I thought ho cow they're right here
next to
me I'm trying to tell him I was like
he's trying to give him commands you
just stop I mean I was going fony
stopping but I
mean I guess it's long fucking tr
there's one on the back of
the
there Bravo I don't unless
they're City too why we
going
I wonder if
this T
6472 is part of the s number as
well
because that's what's on the
back that tutu Bravo Hotel I wonder if
that's part of it as
well
well run it and see what they
say 31
radio 31 I'm go ahead when you get a
chance I'm going to give you that serial
number for the 69 one more
time
well guys one mod to start in the
morning this out feeling
[Applause]
sneak that's why I let me go ahead and
give out all this information y can get
here to
me out you looking at
thing was out bro I see Russ I'm like d
Russ
down be
Tango
22 Bravo
Hotel
1296 yeah
he 7 222 bra hot
12196 yes
ma'am and that's the one they actually
did 59 went to
headquarters
sometimes you get
them sometimes you can get them right
there like East Point right there train
station if they'll if they'll come me
right there on the other side of East
Point start ACD or Atlanta
so if not we'll take him to Fon County
and
or the uh
headquarters not going to meet with us
we're not going to make it easy on
them any other time they'd be on group
me like less than fucking right they're
like too early this
morning
out wait see confirm it that only start
at 85 for I'm pretty sure it's going to
be a valid warant
but before we wake up Ron on a Saturday
morning seeing Ron move
truck he get a new one not not truck
truck about his
F150 did he get him another F150 or he
still got that white one brand new brand
new he'll put all them he'll put all
them lights on
yeah I open the engine
too